hello everyone and welcome to a very
nice game from today's title Tuesday
that was played on chess.com it's a
three plus zero minute bullet game and
it's Magnus Carlsen versus uh pranav and
it features a very very cool opening the
king's Gambit followed by Queen to H5
something I don't think we've had on the
channel so far and you might also notice
that uh the uh the my surroundings are a
bit different the subscriber uh sent me
this he thought it would be a good idea
to mix it up a little bit so I decided
to test it out uh via maybe a video or
two or uh you know I don't know I like
it I was thinking about refreshing the
channel for you know I I think about it
every year I've just never gone around
to do it uh so uh how do you guys like
it let me know in the comments and let's
check out the game so Magnus has the
white pieces and as advertised we do
have the king's Gambit E4 E5 and pawn to
F4 the king's Gambit is on the board uh
Bishop to C5 going for the classical
variation sort of declining the king's
gambling and now Queen the H5 and
although it looks like a weird move you
know that this can't really be good it
puts black in a very awkward uh position
now the the natural e-capters on F4 is
no longer possible now the bishop and C5
will be hanging you could continue with
something like after Queen to H5 you
could continue maybe Knight to C6 just
defending the pawn but then F captures
an E5 again you lost the pawn and how do
you continue D5 of course can be played
but you have to know the line in order
to feel comfortable here so here uh
pranav decided to give up a full Pawn
but for some rapid development he played
Knight to F6 and sacrificed the E5 Pawn
Magnus grabs it with check and now you
have to block with the bishop otherwise
you're going to be down a piece so
Bishop back to E7 and queen to C3 by
Magnus and uh preparing to advance the
pawn to E5 we have castles uh and the
Ponte E5 Knight the E4 now attacks
magnus's Queen and there is a game where
Queen to F3 was played but here just
Queen the E3 and it is now already as of
move 7 that we have a completely new
game so Pawn to D5 defending the Knight
and now just Pawn to D3 challenging the
Knight of course you don't want to
capture Alpha saw the Knight captures
and then it's a very very nice position
for black that uh queen and king and the
foul will not have a great time so after
D5 we have pointed the three challenging
the Knight and now Bishop to C5
attacking the queen and now you can't
just move the queen otherwise you get uh
sorry otherwise you get Knight to F2 and
then the Rook hangs so you have to play
Pawn to D4 which okay maybe not
something you've planned but you do grab
the full Center uh Bishop to B6 and now
Knight to C3 we have Fawn to C5 you have
to open up the position as magnus's king
is still in the center of the board and
Magnus will try to uh avoid that as soon
as possible so first he captures an E4 C
captures on D4 and Ice Vision 2 before
capturing the Knight on e4 Queen to F3
and D captures an E4 uh returning the
queen over to the E4 Square and you
might think okay maybe it's too
dangerous to grab that you can't really
allow the spawn to survive if you just
move the queen then the pawn gets
defended and uh black will just win the
game easily so Queen captures an E4 is a
must Knight the C6 and now Pawn to A3
stopping any Knights the B4 ideas and
also uh you will have B4 at some point
in the future if needed Rook to E8 and
now Bishop to D3 developing the bishop
with the threat of Queen captures on H7
so G6 you could also consider Queen to
H4 with check and if G3 Queen H5 this
will also defend the H7 pawn and now
Pawn to G6 with Knight to F3 now finally
Magnus preparing the castle and while
you could go for something like Bishop
to F5 uh pranav decides to attack the
uh white king he wants to open up the
center he plays Pawn to F6 now while
this does threaten to open up the center
it also weakens the black king somewhat
but like I said it's uh it's a three
minute Blitz game uh we have Castles by
Magnus hiding the king the safety and
now Bishop to G4 not Bishop to F5 right
away he first goes Bishop to G4 H3 and
only now Bishop back to F5 we have Queen
back to E2 and here pranav trades on D3
Bishop captures we have C captures not
Queen capture C captures um
uh also uh also very nice also it opens
up the C file for The Rook if needed and
you uh gain some more central control
here so Queen to D5 putting more
pressure on the E5 pawn and the bishop
to D2 We have F captures on E5 F
captures an E5 Knight captures an E5
Knight captures and now Rook captures on
E5 we have Queen to F2 now you have to
be a little bit careful of course you
know that Bishop to H6 is coming but not
a lot of ways to stop that we have Rook
to F5
attacking the queen on F2 uh Queen to G3
and now Rook a to f8 with Rook captures
on F5 Queen captures an F5 and now
Bishop to H6 and now what you want to
play here is uh Rook to C8 this is your
only move in the position because after
Rook to C8 uh once Magnus gets this Rook
to F1 moving uh you do have Bishop to C7
it is now defended by the rook and
whatever you do you can't really well
you can't really do anything otherwise
as something like Queen E5 we'll put
pressure on the white king so you have
to play Queen F2 you have to offer a
queen trade and uh Prana would have to
trade because if you try Queen to E5 now
then you're the one getting checkmated
Queen to f8 check Rook captures and Rook
captures and f8 with a very nice Queen
sacrifice checkmate uh so instead after
Bishop to H6 uh Rook the d8 was played
and this is just giving magnets a bit
too much this is a precious Tempo uh
Rook to F1 and now Queen to E6 we have
Queen to F3 and here Bishop to C7 was
played but now of course
um you can even pause the video and try
to figure out what Magnus played but I'm
pretty sure you guys have a general idea
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on paying
attention on what I've already referred
to in the video and for those of you who
just want to enjoy the show it is of
course Queen to f8 with check this is
what Magnus played and here at pranav
resigned the game as there is nothing
more to be done here once the queen is
accepted Rook captures an f8 comes with
Checkmate so there you have it very nice
game only 30 moves uh plan of counter
magnus's idea in the opening well he
played it very actively he gave up a
pawn for some activity but even though
he fought hard in the end he lost the
game uh so yeah that's the game I hope
you guys enjoyed it uh uploaded a nice
short Blitz game uh also just to get an
Insight on what you guys think about the
the new interface should we should we
employ it or or is the the old one you
know just the old one or is is a change
maybe better uh so yeah also very
interested in that I would like to thank
David Kimura wrote Hill Phil maltus
Johan Bridger and Richard Phillips for a
contribution to my channel thank you lot
I really appreciate it as usual you can
check two of my previous videos here
thank you for watching and I will see
you soon continuing to check up on you
wonderful suggestions and whatever else
happens in the Chess World so thank you
all I will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day and probably
gonna check up on the uh just.com bullet
Championship see you soon
thank you